nearly 15 years after their original
release pokemon diamond and pearl are
coming to the nintendo switch as
brilliant diamond and shining pearl and
like other pokemon remakes before them
these two games update the classic ds
versions with some modern features so
with the pair's release right around the
corner here's everything you need to
know about pokemon brilliant diamond in
shining pearl
pokemon brilliant diamond and shining
pearl are set in sinnoh a rural region
divided down the middle by mount coronet
as in other pokemon adventures your goal
is to travel across the region defeating
gym leaders and collecting badges to
qualify to challenge the pokemon league
in route you'll cross paths with team
galactic a villainous organization
trying to summon the legendary pokemon
dialga in brilliant diamond and palkia
in shining pearl like other games in the
series you begin your adventure by
selecting a starter pokemon from the
local pokemon expert professor rowan
your three choices in these titles are
the grass type turtle tertwig the fire
type monkey and my favorite chimchar and
the water type pokemon piplup brilliant
diamond and shining pearl look like old
school pokemon games rather than
completely modernizing the classic ds
games brilliant diamond and shining
pearl are staying very faithful to them
featuring the same top down perspective
and chibi art style as the originals
according to the nintendo company the
sense of scale of the original game's
towns and routes have been carefully
preserved in the remakes and players
will encounter the pokemon that appeared
in those nostalgic titles this old
school feel is most apparent in things
like the pokemon center and pokemart
being separate buildings again and
catching wild pokemon once again being
mostly a random affair this means
pokemon won't appear in the overworld
while you're walking through tall grass
or using surf over water the one
exception lies in the new grand
underground where pokemon wander around
and sometimes chase after you in
hideaways similar to the wild area
inserted shield the underground is also
where you can dig for valuable items and
rare pokemon statues to show off in your
secret base many gen 4 exclusive
features return in brilliant diamond and
shining pearl as well like the ability
to bait honey trees to attract wild
pokemon enter enhanced pokemon contests
decorate pokeball seals with stickers
and walk around with your pokemon in
cute parks to strengthen your
relationship
most importantly hidden machines aka hms
return in brilliant diamond and shining
pearl similar to the last few pokemon
games these moves are no longer tied to
a pokemon meaning you don't have to give
up one of their moves just to have them
learn in hm like you did in the original
gen 4 games you used to have to carry
around at least two pokemon that
collectively knew cut
surf strength rock smash
waterfall and rock climb just to get
through gen 4. since you no longer have
to do that it should help you build out
a more balanced team and on top of that
experience share is available from the
start and is applicable to your entire
party in gen 4 you immediately go to
fight the elite four and champion after
completing all eight gyms there's
nothing to do in between making the end
game content a tough hill to climb if
you didn't take the time out to grind
and level all the members of your team
the grind between beating the final gym
and taking on the elite four and
champion should be a lot shorter thanks
to that experience share beyond that
brilliant diamond and shining pearl adds
a host of quality of life improvements
like an auto save feature pokemon move
info a button on the battle screen that
will quickly pull up your pokeball page
so you're not just
searching through menus while trying to
catch a pokemon and a waypoint marker
that will let you know where you need to
go next just in case you're lost
brilliant diamond and shining pearl also
features legendary encounters in
romana's park each encounter can be
triggered using various slates that
correspond to each legendary pokemon
possibly the coolest part these slates
pay homage to game boy cartridges in a
way that is very hard to miss each
pokemon you encounter at these pedestals
depends on what version of the game
you're playing brilliant diamond will
have legends like entei and suicune
shining pearl will have zapdos articuno
and even maltrace additionally you can
link with other games to befriend
mythical pokemon like mew who can be
found using save data from pokemon let's
go pikachu and eevee
although they're separate games
brilliant diamond and shining pearl and
pokemon legends arceus share one big
thing in common the sinnoh region unlike
the remakes however pokemon legends is
set in the distant past before cinna was
fully developed and it charts the
player's journey to create the region's
first pokedex it's unclear if there's
any actual connection between the two
games beyond the settings such as some
kind of bonus for players who have
played both but it appears pokemon
legends will delve further into the lore
behind the region and its titular
mythical pokemon arceus which is said to
have created the world pokemon brilliant
diamond and shining pearl and pokemon
legends arceus will be compatible with
pokemon home however just not at launch
the pokemon company confirmed that
support for the upcoming switch games
will be added to pokemon home sometime
in 2022 once support has been
implemented you'll be able to transfer
pokemon yuko and brilliant diamond and
shining pearl and pokemon legends arceus
and store them in pokemon home beyond
that however details are scanned it
remains unclear if transfers will be one
way as they were with pokemon go
or if you'll be able to bring compatible
pokemon you've caught in other games
from home into brilliant diamond and
shining pearl or legends pokemon
brilliant diamond and shining pearl
launch exclusively on nintendo switch on
november 19 2021 while series creator
game freak developed every previous
pokemon remake to date pokemon brilliant
diamond and shining pearl are instead
being handled by ilca while game freak
works on pokemon legends arceus
and there you have it everything you
need to know about pokemon brilliant
diamond and shining pearl if you found
this video useful make sure you hit the
like button and subscribe to gamespot
for more pokemon coverage
[Music]
you